hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm joined by Rosanna pansino hello
posing on Raw she does nerdy nummies
never if you're wondering why the hell
I'm talking like is it cuz squeezing my
neck into my jaw anyway welcome to the
wet head challenge ultimate edition a bi
Ultimate Edition it means that we're
putting some risk into this we're gonna
play a game of rock-paper-scissors
whoever wins let's say it's me gets the
right to put on this hat and wager a
number up to seven cuz wagering eight
would be really stupid
um even the regulator's better only
suggest two at a time but who knows how
many turns it's gonna take to make this
hat of death for water and we've
replaced all the water with battery acid
was we were gonna do unless what we are
playing to how many points that's all we
need twelve and what 15 we know the
rules thirteen and a half
I'll fudge the rules when I start losing
the HIPAA it makes sense good
ready yeah rocked a person seat yes okay
so now we're off to a good start so I
put on the little helmet here uh-huh
alright strap it to my head because
safety is first prior or they're on this
thing right I'm wagering three I'm gonna
pull three pins is freshly spun I can't
talk oh my god it hurts
Oh 100 I'm okay 200 I'm okay recommended
about the whole spitter alleles ones and
twos three I'm okay I'm alright there's
a little water dripping but it's not the
deluge that it was gonna be three points
here says you shoot Rock Paper Scissors
shoot
yes oh I'll go over to looking for 200
mark Oh mark my hair my brush is here
that way you don't get the boys yeah I
don't get the points I don't even get
water Don you don't get the points all
right we need a refill okay get it way
Hanlan's gotta be freshly spun Oh mark
will you wear my headband only if you
want me to Oh looking good thank you
okay could you see out of you bad you
don't need to see only need to pull oh I
got a wager a number okay let's go what
did you pick the first one three three
yeah I'm gonna do grid
no no 33 okay yeah you pull out the beer
pull out the pin yeah oh jeez look what
are the technical difficulties guys we
got this oh okay
man you've like switch between three
different huh I feel like one of those
was the death one of them to death oh no
which one was it
oh okay I'm feeling lucky I feel like
this is a good one no yeah slowly is 3 2
0 still favor says you shoot up here
Thank You Tommy I'm Susie yes
oh yeah in the wheel of death here
lotta noise just sounds medieval like
it's like an old rickety like turning
crank or like stretching people out oh
I'll go through three grand
okay one two okay I don't even know if I
want to win this rock paper scissors
okay but I do Davis is you yes oh no I'm
taking this back
Oh how's my lucky lucky hub and I need
it back okay score 6-0 let's do this
fierce is shoot prepare to shoot okay
all right away oh okay that's huh I'm
just gonna go for two this time no go
for three go bang what's the harm I win
for three you're damaged chaos oh that's
true yeah I just want a clean sweep a
13mm are you trying to strategy me yeah
okay I'm going for two first one
okay one pin down second one to go okay
you actually got some points which is
amazing two points this is cute sing it
good
okay I'm gonna go for two as well what
are the odds loop ends right next to the
woman's who chokes you're gonna be bad
huh okay all right okay okay done three
maybe oh I'm sure I got eight how do we
do I have yeah - okay not favorite
didn't you yeah okay I'm just gonna do
one oh sorry the very dangerous hat
right now I'm mark this is a dangerous I
don't work okay which pin is gonna get
me I just want one yeah okay I feel like
this one's gonna be good so I'm gonna go
the opposite
yeah why do you look at me so creepy
look at I'm shot oh okay
that's my shocked face I'm shocked that
that works I was thought it was the
battery acid is dissolved Crisco
so you have three points congratulations
sake you really climb in the leaderboard
yeah Rock Paper Scissors - Rock Paper
Scissors - Rock Paper Scissors shoot ah
oh good luck with that
look I'm gonna go ahead I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go with this one
oh come on that's not fair
please I got four please you're just
Mikkel and I'm in your way okay this is
a shoot
yes yeah yeah going for one just one you
don't wanna try - I think two would be
this tragedy you're funny you're real
funny marker you know funny guy yeah hey
alright say - for mm-hmm I'm gonna win
this and we're going to 15 unless maybe
it gets too close and then we're gonna
extend it so I win oh shoot yes yes all
right I'm gonna go I'm gonna go for four
whoa
[Music]
to it once to it died okay fine 32 these
two yeah okay I felt some water dripping
oh look wait no yeah okay Mac uses you
Thanks
I mean well thanks mark you're welcome
I'm in it for you okay I'm gonna go for
the one just one oh I really like the
one boring yeah
boring to be mild over here you know
what I'm gonna go with the one right in
the front okay it's like a unicorn and I
love unicorns
if you pull its horn off don't you kill
it girl right you got four I want to see
if this analogy holds through okay we'll
just test it out it's a lie if you
didn't kill it
I'll tear your shoes ah listen Simon
lead over to no I don't want that this
is reverse okay
rock paper scissors I don't want this
one Rock Paper Scissors shoot
no yeah maybe it's broken and it's not
gonna and no water is gonna come out
okay so this is what
we're boy and you win the games 14 to 5
how can I lose this it's not a close
game but I'm a good sport maybe I could
have a comeback probably no they're
probably not Rock Paper Scissors shoot
oh maybe a comeback
I hope you get it on the for you didn't
spin it you didn't spin it you gotta
spin it I have to spin it at the
beginning you have to ready how many you
doing I'm doing a lot now yeah yeah I'm
gonna use a lot too
that's very good jokes oh okay I'm not
gonna think about it's gonna good I'm
just gonna go because when I think mad
things happen so I'm just gonna think
about happy thoughts and puppies and my
little dog cookie and she's so cute and
I love her and hope nope yeah mommy
loves you
shoot rock paper scissor shoot yes yes
I'll be a good sport
okay I'll pull for maybe you should pull
three three threes good three three have
to learn more than I need right three
more marks three look a lot of pins
right it all comes down to this three
pins mark washi paper scissors shoot yes
right mark you only need one to win I
feel like I should play a really epic
song for you right now but I don't
handle it
[Music]
Rock Paper Scissors shoot oh is it is
come back Molly how many points I have
five five okay
all I need is ten all right I'm gonna go
for three that's a good number
oh the talk no no
yes you did go paper first time I'm
learning now you go paper first every
time you don't know my strategy that is
that it's exactly what you do I'll go
for one it's good it's gonna be this one
this is bullcrap robbery soon as you not
gonna do shoot yes I know 9 to 14 9 to
14 mark I'm catching that ok I'm coming
and we can we swap over to the shoot hey
Kiki Kiki hearings very aggravated
papers in and under the rocks 3 ok
one two three this is such crap this is
crap pointed out a very scary suit yes
okay what are the odds that it would be
the firm one it's impossible you only
need one you got this mark pick a good
one yes I won I won I won it all this
was at stake
whoever one gets a diamond play button I
won and I earned it too cuz I suffered a
lot at the cruel hands of fate so thank
you so much for joining us thank you for
over being here that was quite a
comeback
it was getting close thank you I wonder
if you had gone for six to go for the
win if that would have been the better
way to go about it but we'll never know
and be sure to check out ROS channel for
another challenge that we did that was
very similar this is what the stakes
were just as I was just as intense and
who knows who would win I don't know
because fate is a cruel
now that's four that's their middle name
xxxx she was a cool was it cruel bit
wait what's her first name you guys
figure that out for yourself thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye